francis do you enjoy social media of
course i love spending my days being
called a fat bigot by strangers
and do you think the woke buyers on
social media is getting ridiculous
yeah what happened to pilot was a
travesty for freedom of speech online
what if i told you there was a brand new
social media platform that encouraged
free speech
that's brilliant will it be able to show
off my sick abs on it as well
hopefully not the new platform is called
retalk and it is
absolutely exploding right now they have
discussion forums around any topic
from gardening to ancient history all
the way to current politics
that sounds great but a lot of these
free speech platforms
just attract all the worst people from
both sides
or as we call them here trigonometry
fans correct
joking aside what makes retalk different
is it's moderated to keep away
extremists but instead of being uber
work they take a balanced view to
moderation
wow how do they find so many moderators
who don't have pink hair i don't know
maybe they hire people from all over the
political spectrum
great joke mate no big tech company
would ever do that
retalk insists on civility and they're
particularly keen to foster
conversations for people in the center
and on the center right
you can even go on there and discuss
trigonometry and your favorite episodes
so all i need to do to access this great
site is click on the link and it will
take me straight there yep and if you're
a listener
go to retalk.com that's r e t
a l k dot com and start having
intelligent conversations you know
they'll be intelligent conversations
because francis hasn't worked out how to
join yet
i haven't why wouldn't someone
who actually comes from a country where
it's ingrained and inculcated into them
that the islamic identity is superior
why would they adopt your identity when
you yourself say
we're actually nothing our values mean
nothing
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster
i'm constantine kissin and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
it does not get better than the guest we
have for you this week
she's an author activist and scholar
ayan hershely
welcome to trigonometry thank you very
much for having me on and it's a great
pleasure for us to have you on the show
uh listen we were talking just before
the show started about the fact that
there's now a whole generation of young
people who may not even be familiar
with the entirety of your journey they
might be familiar with your later work
but not
with with the whole journey that you've
had through life so for those people
give everybody an overview
of how are you where you are sitting
here talking to us
so um well my name is ayan hershey ali
and i was born in somalia i'm a
very old woman
i think if you hit 50 then that's when
age sort of comes after you
when i was born in 1969 my father was a
politician
and we left somalia when i was about
seven or eight years old
and we moved around i lived in saudi
arabia i lived in ethiopia i lived in
kenya
and in 1992 when i was
22 years old my father decided
that it was time for me to get married
and he picked a husband for me
i didn't agree with that
arrangement but i also have to make it
very clear that that's just how it works
in our culture
he was trying to do what's best for his
daughter
and i think he had a sense of guilt
because he had been gone for 10 years
uh so he left when i was about 11 years
old and came back when i was 22 years
old
and at that time i thought he had no
business arranging anything for me
uh aside from me not liking the man that
he selected for me
i was then sent to germany to stay with
a relative
who was going to help us figure out um
the the immigration process from germany
to canada
the man that my father married me off to
was a canadian
somali but instead of going to canada
i slipped into the netherlands and i
asked for asylum
and i lived there for 10 happy years and
then 9 11
2001 happened and i took
a position in that debate that was not
popular
um and that sort of launched me into i
you know one day i was a complete
unknown i just graduated
and started my first job at a think tank
and a few weeks later i was the
sensation of the nation
and um you talk to some people and they
would say
famous and some people will say infamous
and then fast forward i i went into
politics i served in the dutch
parliament for about three years
and then i
um
comments that were considered
blasphemous
um by by muslims
including my family and my relatives and
the wider muslim community and that led
to the dutch government deciding to
put me in a security scheme where i was
you know i was i had gods 24 7.
[Music]
and because i had guides 24 7
i didn't end up the way my friend theo
van gogh ended
who was killed by an islamist who
thought that he blasphemed
theo unfortunately and i made a small
film
together where we were trying to show
that the awful horrible treatment
of women um in um
in islam is not just you know it's not
just
incidental that there is a whole
ideology behind it
and that it's sanctioned by the koran
and that was offensive
uh enough to this young man called
mohammed bieri
that he plotted to kill both of us but
he was able to get to theo
because theo didn't have the same um
security uh or sort of
24 7
[Music]
bubble that i was in and that kept me
safe of course and i'm grateful for that
but in shock that's my background
and then you move to america where i
believe you still have to have
bodyguards so tell everybody ayan
what are these great crimes that you've
committed what are the words that you've
said or the things that you've done
that make you as you said infamous
well i think the first um and i would
say
the crime that for instance my family
think is unforgivable
is that i said i'm no longer a muslim i
just don't believe in allah or muhammad
and then i took it one step further
and instead of just saying i don't
believe in
the moral superiority of muhammad i
started to describe things that he said
and did and
to this day people do and say it's
justified
in the name of religion because they
follow in the footsteps of muhammad
and and so i i judged muhammad by the
moral standards of
our day um and that
put me in even more trouble
um and then when in the netherlands
like right after 9 11 we weren't just
having conversations about terrorism
in the netherlands we were also having
conversations about
the failure uh to integrate
muslim minorities and not just the first
generation but the second generation and
sometimes even
going down to the grandchildren and
i looked into it and i came to the
conclusion that
if we allow muslim communities to
continue treating
girls and women the way they do they
will continue to lag behind
and integration is just not going to
happen
i was talking about such features as
female genital mutilation
i was talking about pulling little girls
out of school and marrying them off
abducting them sometimes taking them to
the country of origin forcing them into
marriages that they didn't want to
or importing young men from very remote
parts
of morocco and turkey and other places
and then having these
girls who were born and raised in
holland and they would be married off
and and there was something
transactional about that and inhuman
and i wasn't supposed to talk about that
stuff
but my conclusion was if you want
integration to succeed emancipate these
young women
and then as the conversations about
terrorism continued because terrorist
acts
continued most of our prominent leads
were saying
islam is a religion of peace and i
thought
that it was nonsense i didn't just think
that i also said it i wrote about it
i tried to to demonstrate
that it's um
it's very difficult to maintain this
notion
uh that political islam is what i'm
talking about i'm not
i'm not talking about muslims here who
are just peaceful people and identify as
muslim i'm talking about the people
who organize and raise money
and preach and develop a narrative
and then act on that narrative and
wage jihad or holy war
and i just thought it was very strange
to say that
it's a religion of peace when in fact
we were seeing acts of violence from
like the beheading of theo van gaal
all the way to attempts to blow up
uh innocent people um
in you know going about their business
in recreational areas
and so i i lived through the time
when uh the hotels in bombay
uh were attacked
but also when boko haram
the leader of whom studied in saudi
arabia
and you know he imbibed
the ins and outs of sharia law in mecca
and medina
and then went back to nigeria and then
established an organization called boko
haram
and then started terrorizing the
population so it goes in terms of
scale it goes from you know attacks
against
individuals all the way to the
um the the
upsetting of countries and then
obviously we saw the phenomenon of
isis where uh
these outfits that call themselves the
islamic state of iraq and syria
invaded and occupied large swathes
of iraq and syria and subjected the
people of iraq and syria
to not only
a theocracy uh that they
justified in the name of islam
but that we were seeing in real time
because this is the kind of
world we live in now where those
perpetrators were saying
we are acting in this way say against
yazidi women
because this is what the quran tells us
this is exactly what muhammad did and so
we're trying to replicate
these things and so i think voicing
these things
linking them to islam
famous with a group of people infamous
with others
so ayon why do you think that we're not
able to have a sensible rational
discussion about islam
not about muslims but about the
religion and the ideas behind it
well here are some i'm just going to run
you through some of the reasons
that i hear and to answer that
particular question
um there's a there are a lot of stories
about
um when you say we um
assuming western society yes absolutely
um that we have to atone for all the
things that western
civilization has done wrong
um slavery colonization
the occupation of other countries uh
waging wars
um the first world war the second world
war
the way the jewish people were treated
um
so i think there is this um and and i i
hear that i acknowledge
all of that history but uh we end up
just telling
one side of the story we we only tell
the story of all the terrible things
that um
that western leaders over the centuries
have done
we don't tell the other side of the
story we also we don't tell the story of
um it was the british
uh who took the initiative in ending
slavery
the arabs didn't end it the chinese
didn't end it um
other civilizations didn't and we don't
tell that story
uh we had a war in america a civil war
that almost
ripped the country apart
and that was about ending slavery we had
subsequent
conflicts about not just ending slavery
but ending segregation
we had the whole story of civil rights
we don't tell these stories we also
don't
tell the stories of what other
civilizations have done wrong
and so we are in this we've got to atone
for the past
by um
i would say just talking about what we
did wrong
and we're pushed into a place where the
only way
we are told in the age of identity
politics
is the only way to atone for it is
um
[Music]
to to look away
from uh in in my
view injustices perpetrated by people of
color
and uh non-christians in this case the
religion of islam
um and i don't i don't agree with that
approach we're just being told be quiet
and
let's sit tight and suffer let's
the victims of those ideologies suffer
let's be patient and then one day i
suppose
we'll wake up and and what
so john what would you say to those
people who say that having these
conversations putting forward these
types of arguments
is emboldening the far right well there
are extreme rights groups
just like there are extreme left-wing
groups but let me focus now on the
extreme rights and the populists
um and they are the only ones in town
right now
who are talking about these issues
and if you want to empower them
i think the way to do it is to censor
and to self-censor rational people
who are in the middle people who are not
hostile to immigrants who are not
necessarily hostile to islam
who are not hostile to women who are not
hostile to immigration in general
center left center right established an
establishment
parties and elites when they say we're
not going to talk about these
issues then you leave the door wide
open for these fringe groups to come in
and take
control of the narrative of some of
these big
issues of our time and that's
unfortunate
ayan you talked earlier about being
infamous and
i can totally see that with some of the
arguments that you're putting forward
why someone who's a muslim or even
frankly an islamist
like the sort of people you're
criticizing would be angry with you
what i understand a lot less and i mean
a lot less
is how somebody who grew up in the west
is a product of this sort of culture
who's not in any way affected by the
words that you're saying
uh why are they so angry with you
because look
you might be completely wrong uh but you
have a right to express these ideas
surely
exactly and i i mean it's all everybody
is welcome
to dislike me to challenge
my assertions um
i think that's enriching i think it's
empowering i think it's a good thing
um but i think
we and i know you've done a number of
shows on this but
we live in this age where i mean
here in america um we call it the
culture wars
worry ayan we import everything you guys
produce over there a couple of years
later so thank you very much we've got
our own culture war
we're very grateful for it i know i know
we produce here in america a lot of good
things that
go across the world and then we also
produce really bad things
like identity politics and that also
unfortunately goes across the world
and here we are but there is um
we live it's a it's a crazy context
because we live in
and you get you really describe that
very well
so people actually sane people rational
well-educated people
will make statements like i don't like
so-and-so
uh and then you say but why would you
like so and you've never met so-and-so
you've never really engaged with someone
so why don't you like them
and it's just that because they think
they belong in
that camp now when i discuss
and i and that's what i was doing in the
past couple of decades
islam or when some of my friends talk
about christianity or judaism
you see people organized along religious
lines and say
i belong to this particular religious
camp and people who belong in that other
camp
i don't like them i don't think that
their approach to
god or morality or sanity or society is
a good thing
um but there was the i think we
understood it
the framework was always religion and
and then we were trying and the rest of
us uh either moderately religious
agnostic or atheist
we would say well we've got to
to compel them to moderate
now we're faced with this and it's
really amazing
um this pseudo-religious a secular
movement
born out of these postmodernists um
web of ideas and thoughts and it's you
know it's it's a mishmash of things
but it has now uh coalesced into again
in america we call it cancer culture
we call it woke it's got all sorts of
different names
um but they um
they the people who adhere to these
post-modernist
uh ideas they say they have the last one
just
they have the last one on equality they
have the last word on
anything a concerning grace
gender
and these people are not going to like
me or people like me
because i just have the same attitude to
them as i do to the islamists which is
i don't really care what arguments you
make to shut down
free inquiry free discussion free
debates
the fact that you're doing it is wrong
and
and here's why you are wrong and those
people are not going to like me
and so what i don't understand right is
the people we're talking about they
would claim that they are
all about protecting women all about
protecting sexual minorities
and you're criticizing what you call
political islam which let's be
you know let's put it with british
understatement it's an ideology that
doesn't exactly have the best record
on those issues shouldn't they be your
allies on this
you would think that you would think
that when they say they actually
are engaged in
speaking for and giving a voice to
minorities groups that didn't have a
voice
the transgender community women
[Music]
blacks people of color
any any group that they identify
as having been victimized in the past
um so you know in the first naive moment
that's
that's what you think they're doing and
then you
dig deeper into um
[Music]
into the ideology and the logic of their
ideology and the way they
they express themselves and the way they
use
language and these
matrixes that they've made to
heterosexual
males at the top he's the oppressor
guilty of toxic masculinity
and then you come down the ladder people
of color etc
if you look into all of this what you're
going to discover is
um that in fact they are not
interested in protecting
the rights of women all the rights of
any of the other minorities
that they have given um
they've categorized them in this matrix
of victims
they're just not interested in it what
they're really interested in aside from
virtue signaling and and showing the
world that they're morally superior
what they're really interested in is
acquiring
power and money
and um
not doing or getting to these things the
way the rest of us are expected to
which is through hard work and
distinguishing yourself because you've
put
10 000 hours into being accomplished at
something
but by guilt-tripping people into saying
uh well if you don't give me that
particular position of power
or this pay or that promotion
you're racist you are sexist
you know this that and the other and
it's just
oh that they are i would say in terms of
intellectual
accomplishments a lot of these people
are inferior and they're just
masking that inferiority with
this type of of narratives and
storytelling
we are now being told working hard
getting up in the morning having a goal
trying to achieve all of that is
whiteness there you go mate you're not
as white as you thought
delighted absolutely delighted
hey constantin are you feeling fragile
of course
i'm a full-blooded toxic straight white
male
then i have the perfect book for you
it's called woke fragility
what's it about it's a satirical
takedown of the woke movement
poking funner all the nonsense and the
ridiculous arguments
we're forced to endure day after day
ah so it's a parody of robin d'angelo's
white fragility a favorite of middle
class white gimps everywhere there is
nothing wrong with being a lower middle
class white [ __ ]
anyway the great thing about the book is
that it's not gratuitous
or incendiary it's a light-hearted and
playful book
written by someone on the left who's as
incredulous
at this idiocy as we are i'm guessing he
hasn't been able to find a publisher
because
well for the reasons that we all know so
where do i get a copy for my one
remaining work friend
search woke fragility on amazon or just
hit the link in the description
all right well what happens if i don't
read it i'll buy you a copy of white
fragility instead
get me a copy of woke fragility stat
finally i've figured out what it takes
to make him behave
so moving on to your latest book pray
which i'm going to be honest with you is
a brilliant book but
incredibly incredibly difficult to read
it's very very challenging
it deals with the issue of first
generation refugees coming to the west
and then the crimes that they commit
against women
in these countries why did you feel that
this was such an
important topic to tackle
it's first of all it's a big problem
that affects
women um
it's a problem that i know people don't
want
like we talked about earlier people
don't want to talk about islam they
don't want to talk about immigration
all of these issues have been declared
too sensitive to touch
um but the scale of immigration is
growing
and it's con it will continue to grow
um before i got on your show i was
reading uh united nations
united nations reports uh that was
saying because of kobe 19
very frail economies will be disrupted
that will lead to food shortages that is
going to lead to conflicts
that is then going to lead to an exodus
of young people mainly young men
from africa middle east south asia
any number of the countries where many
of these immigrants come from
and they will they will be heading to
europe and other wealthy nations
and many of them will not make it and
some of them will make it
now just uh let's say
keep that in your mind and then you move
on to
the minorities from those particular
places
uh first generation second generation in
europe
and we were having great difficulty
assimilating them
into the value system of the host
societies
so we have this problem of assimilating
people who've been coming since the
1960s 70s 80s again
not all of them
but a large enough group that is causing
social cohesion problems
now we're having this but we had the
waves of 2015
and according to the prognosis there'll
be even more
um that sort of
uh i would say large-scale human
movement always creates
disruptions the subject of this book is
it's affecting women in
negative ways not and for years i wrote
about
immigrant women themselves like i told
you muslim women
were subjected to female gender
mutilation uh subjected to
child marriage subjected to what we call
it's an umbrella name called honor
violence
where it's basically the men in your
family who tells you what you can't
encounter and so the freedoms and rights
of immigrant women were constrained
we decided that was taboo we weren't
going to say much about it there have
been cons
conversations about it they've been a
lot of activism
but we really didn't deal with the
problem the way we should have
now the problem is spilling over and
this is the subject of prey
into the public space and it's affecting
all women
immigrant and local or native or white
or whatever you want to call them
and it's affecting mostly
and here i think it's easier to talk to
british people because you understand
class it's
affecting working-class women more than
anyone else
so we had the me too movement that
started here
again that came to your shores and
beyond
i thought it was a good thing that
movement was about
um about
addressing the workplace as
a workplace has to be a safe place for
women
and it wasn't and and that erupted it
was a good thing
but it didn't trickle down to the masses
and masses of working-class women
who are in fact victims of
sexual misconduct and
what i focus on in the book is sexual
misconduct
perpetrated by some immigrant
men many of them from muslim majority
countries
who were born and raised in places
where the attitude to women is radically
different
from the western countries that they're
coming to
it's a taboo to link islam
immigration and the erosion of women's
rights
but it has to be done i know you had a
gruesome
debate in the united kingdom about the
pakistani gangs
targeting working class vulnerable
children i want to call them children
because that's exactly what they were
right they were under 18 most of them
and
it took what decades for
british society to come out and protect
these girls they were betrayed in every
way possible
all because the people who were supposed
to protect them
didn't want to be called racist
xenophobic
or bigoted they made a trade-off
and the trade-off was i'm just going to
have these
i'll i'll i'll ignore the abuse and
betrayal of these children
because i don't want the contraception
and this
this this problem that i address in the
book
same thing everyone uh every official
that i have spoken to
starts by saying i really am not a
racist
it's even racism to raise the subject or
some of them
will admit that there is a problem but
they don't want their name
because it's going to affect their
political careers
some of them will say um
you know we have knowledge yes it's a
problem it's a big problem it's a
growing problem
but hey i am what are we gonna do about
it
i've had the phrase you take some of
these young men uh you send them to
prison
for perpetrating all sorts of sexual
offenses
and they go like this or they're going
as a rapist and they come out as a
terrorist
so it isn't only that there is a taboo
but when you cut across the censorship
and people
open up there is a sense of hopelessness
and powerlessness and resignation
these are terrible problems but what can
we do
and that person yeah it frustrates all
of us as you know we've had
dr ella hill on the show who's a
survivor of of one of these
gangs and you know it's obviously a
tragic situation but
the problem with it we found is that you
know the moment you start talking about
these issues
people start calling you names they
start questioning your motives they
start
you know putting you in political groups
in which you don't belong
and you know you said it yourself right
now quote unquote it's only the far
right talking about it but really
what happens is anyone who talks about
it becomes far right
in people's eyes right so how do we how
do we break that deadlock
how do you undo that i think you unmask
that the labeling um
the you know accusations bigotry and so
on
it's a cover-up for incompetence
it's a cover-up for the fact that these
people who
um have made their way um
to government or you know positions
they're elected positions of power
uh basically saying uh shut up
because they don't have an answer and
they don't want to seek an answer
so there's there is i mean i've seen it
as a cover-up
for incompetence i've seen it up close
it's not that these people are bad
people
it's that very often they're focused on
their careers
and the issues of immigration islam
women's
rights that sort of thing it's not a
career enhancing
yeah you're very good at british
understatement aryan yeah
they're career breaking issues i've
spoken to one of the british
members of parliament for labor uh as
champion
and she was punished when she spoke
about
these and so so then she was demoted and
and now she had to go back
and we tried to talk to her again and
she said i
i'm really sorry i think you know male
aggression is universal
and and she mumbles something about
all men being bad and it's just
the attitude was please leave me alone
and i understand that because she
she suffered but she isn't the only one
i spoke to a german minister who said
please don't use my name
i see these problems um but what am i
going to do
yeah i mean i think we need to then get
to that next step of then what are we
going to do
and let me give you why i'll just tell
you one thing why i
am a little hopeful
um for the last year all of us have been
locked down
you i would have been in your studio
because i love coming to the uk
and i think you're in london uh london
is one of my favorite cities in the
world
we would be sitting together now having
this conversation instead of
having to do it virtually we're not
doing that because
our governments have said
we are making um the decision
that locking down the economy locking
you down is going to save lives
so the thing is it can be done
if you if you see protecting women and
children as a priority
the government can do it and they can do
it very quickly
instead of having us you know muddle
through
these data that is not really
data it's a tool it's just it's really a
tool for obfuscation
it is possible to gather the data of
you know there's an increase in sexual
violence against women
who are the perpetrators we're going to
note down
not only their names and their dates of
birth
but also their skin color their religion
their background etc
it can be done i know that denmark is
having a conversation about whether to
do it or whether or not to do it
i see all the cons but i also see the
pros
but to be honest with you it can be done
and if you do it and you have this kind
of data
that then can open the door
to assimilation programs that
will be tailor-made to if you're from
syria or tunisia
or pakistan you've come from an
environment
that has shaped you and so in order to
assimilate you
we're going to say ah so this is your
background just like we have health
background checks
this is what you need to know if you
come from india
it's going to be something different if
you come from china it's going to be
something different if you're from
poland it's going to be something
different but this attitude
that all cultures and all religions are
the same and we shouldn't
we really should not see is these
cultural differences
that is what's um
that's what has led to in my view this
sense of
what can we do we can't do anything
about it
and aryan what responsibilities does the
west have
to take in refugees number one and
number two
how do we integrate them once they
arrive in our shores
i think
[Music]
it just depends on how you define the
what responsibility
um i'm i came to holland as a refugee
and i'm really grateful forever for
the dutch taking me in
and giving me the pathway
to the life that i now lead and did i
see that as their responsibility
no i saw it as a gesture and expression
of compassion
and uh in that sense as fellow human
beings
and i believe in universal human
rights universal human
connections so i would say
that gesture of compassion is really a
fantastic thing
do you want to call it responsibility
you can
but i don't want responsibility to mean
then
that uh you can express the compassion
and then uh just let things be
because let me put it differently we
live in nation states
we elect our governments in western
society we pay
taxes and so your primary responsibility
as a government
is to the people who pay those taxes and
who votes
you in government and if women
in the united kingdom france belgium
the netherlands sweden denmark are
feeling
unsafe in the public space because of
this you know
immigration or
that gesture of compassion and i think i
would use the
responsibility in terms of protecting
the rule of law protecting those women
protecting the freedom of speech and so
on
now in terms of how we interact and
react to
the dispossessed outside of our borders
i don't think the time the the the
the accuracy time is responsibility
i think the accurate time maybe would be
compassion
it would be um a rightly understood
self-interest
if we build the economies in africa and
the middle east
and so on maybe we wouldn't have these
large waves
of immigration in our borders
in that case yes it's a responsibility
but it's you're still talking about a
responsibility
to your own people and a good outcome of
that
is that millions of other people are
helped
it's like the way we're discussing the
virus
it doesn't help to just develop a
vaccine
only for the rich west
by vaccinating people in the south in
poor areas
that's an act of generosity but it's
also
an act of rightly understood
self-interest
and so i think we should be having all
of these conversations about
what what can we do about this mass
exodus
of people from continents like africa
middle east south asia i mean you can't
absorb all of them
you can't you just can't it's
overwhelming it's overwhelming the
asylum system i tried to to address
in the book how the immigration
asylum system that was established in
1951
just doesn't it that framework
is not an answer to the reality of today
which is about millions and millions and
millions of people
when that framework was established for
individuals
that's a good point ayan so imagine for
a second and it will be a horrible thing
to imagine
that francis and i are in charge of the
british government and you've got an
opportunity to talk to us
what would you say western governments
should do
vis-a-vis the current immigration
population uh the current immigrant
population the
the refugee population the future
immigration all of those things what
would be the policy
recommendations that you would have for
a western government in
that sort of position so if you start
with
the populations that are already inside
europe you have
obviously those immigrants who have
successfully adapted
and are just doing perfectly fine i
would say listen to them
and it does pay to see what is it that
they did that made them so successful
and then you have the other groups who
have just
failed at integration or assimilation
whatever it is that you call it in the
uk
i would make it a top priority to
try and assimilate those groups you're
going to
end up with a group that i just
they they somehow they just won't do it
and i think there you have to start
talking about
repatriation just offer them and i i
know some of these programs exist
where it is you know you live in london
you've been on welfare for what's 20
something years
uh would you like to go to your country
of origin and
we will give you uh
some resources to start life then to be
around your family
i've seen that happen i have seen
success stories there that is the
integration question
um now there's a subset of people that
are
saying they completely understand the
norms and the values but they don't want
to integrate they're the
the fanatics the islamists and those
i would literally give them the choice
to say we're not and here's where i
think
integration becomes a conversation about
values
and the government would then have to
say the prevailing values
of british values this is who we are
this is our identity our national
identity our values
our norms our laws and
um you don't like it you get out
so in terms of integration you will
always have that
the the carrot and the stick where you
incentivize people
to integrate in if they fail they're
always looking at it
when it comes to what we are looking
this isn't immigration
because i think immigration is just a
cover-up word
for the displacement of
large numbers of people because of
conflict famine
drought all sorts of things
and that is i would say
it's a foreign policy issue combined
with the defense department
combined with allying with other
countries to say
how can we how can we help
these economies and these other
societies
um keep it together so that
you know people don't just go around
causing instability
this is not kovik blessing
yeah i think it's the onset of spring
but but i think that that big picture
conversation about push factors pull
factors
uh which was only in the realm of
academics
who study migration cycles and migration
numbers i think this now really has to
come into the governments
and and i understand that the time is
not right with the pandemic
with brexit with all sorts of
you know um whatever is going on in
china right now i think
china is on everyone's mind at the
moment
but still the
um again reading those u.n reports
the number of people on their way
who attempting is getting ever bigger
ever younger and most of them
sometimes up to 70 of them unaccompanied
young men
now that's not going to end well you can
anticipate that as a government you can
have maybe
a minister or i don't know a department
look at it and say
oh gosh this is coming at us what should
we do
unfortunately most governments just
think
why don't we just close the borders and
then discover
there is such a thing as porous borders
[Laughter]
ion what would you say to these people
who say that these
islamists are a tiny percentage of the
refugee population
and actually most refugees all they want
is to come to
this country or another country and have
a better life for themselves and their
children
well the people who say that let's
if they said that in the 70s and 80s and
90s
um those people was you know
that particular point was interesting
but right now it's
distracting it's not it's it's just a
euphemism for saying
i have no idea what to do and neither
should you
and so let's just lie back and just let
things
uh fall apart and i think
again that's where we are getting into
competence issues
because if you say that you come across
you want
to come across as being virtuous and
moral and reasonable
and but in fact
voters just see right through it and
think what an idiot
ayanna do you think that this is the
only way
that this can happen if basically
people feel strongly enough about this
that they start putting pressure on
politicians
is that the only way that this gets
addressed people looking at some of the
things you're covering in the book some
of the things that frankly have already
happened
and you know there's a enough of a
concern in the in the public
that that starts to put a pressure on
politicians is that the only way that
this ever gets addressed
yes i think the only way to focus a
politician's
mind is the threat of losing votes and
what we are seeing
now in several european countries who
took large numbers of
immigrants mainly from muslim majority
countries
is that there are parties emerging
out of nowhere some of them extreme
rights and far right some of them
populist
but in any case taking on these topics
and it's not just immigration they're
taking on also the issue of
how much of our freedoms and laws and
rights and
national identities should we um
outsource to brussels um
and when politicians find that oh god
they're losing votes
that focuses the mind and and then they
start to address the issues
but then you get into these cycles where
um
i remember angela merkel saying oh
multiculturalism has
failed in an election year and she won
the election
but then when she got reelected
um that whole issue of immigration
integration was put to the lowest part
of the priority
list but now this party the i think it's
called the af
afd or something the afd has emerged and
it's getting ever bigger and it's
getting more voters
and i think that's frightening the
establishment parties in germany
you see the same development in france
marine le pen
keeps you know she she's france's
nightmare
um if you look at sweden and i think
sweden is really
the basket case when it comes to the
failure of integration
or you know nurturing all of these
taboos and censorships
uh and pretending that
all is well they call themselves and
this is really funny
um they call themselves a moral
superpower
and so while they're trying to be a
moral supervisor
on the ground all these problems are
getting out of control and they have the
swedish democratic party i don't know is
that
party far-right or populist or a bit of
both
but in any case it's now focusing the
minds of the swedish politicians into
saying okay okay okay now we have a
problem
you know what and as a result of this do
you think that we're going to see
western democracies
in crisis they are already in crisis
western democracies are already in a
crisis
i think the answer is sorry the the real
question is how do we respond
to the crisis and i think it will have
to start
with the crisis of addressing the
values what is it that makes britain
unique what are british values what are
dutch values what are
french values you know the republic
what are american values and i think we
once you know we have these
movements this post-modernist movement
with all of it
since where we started with um the
selective
um telling of the history of how we were
all awful in
the atonement um thing
um but if you carry on doing lights if
you you know if you maintain you know
well there's nothing unique about
britain or british nurse
first that nothing unique uh nothing
special about
any of our values and then we were just
really these bad people we were
colonizing and we were enslaving and we
were raping we doing all in this the
only story you can tell is we were just
awful people
why do you i mean it's really it's
mind-boggling
why wouldn't someone who actually
comes from a country where it's
ingrained and inculcated into them
that the islamic identity is superior
why would they adopt your identity when
you yourself
say we're actually nothing our values
mean nothing so i think we'll have to
have that conversation about
values and national identity versus
identity politics
what matters and what doesn't matter
that's a really good point and frankly
music to my ears you know i'm an
immigrant first generation in this
country myself francis is from an
immigrant background as well
and it never made any sense to me that
we have these conversations where
it's like you know the people are
embarrassed to admit that there's such a
bri
thing as british identity you know and
as you say it's a really good point if
if someone already has a strong identity
why on earth
would they adopt some kind of
wishy-washy
evil bad history identity when frankly
they've got better options yeah i mean
i don't i know that this is
a comedy show and we have um
need to add a little bit of fun into it
but
i watch someone like hugh grant
and maybe i'm from afghanistan or iraq
or pakistan
and i'm male and i think what the i
don't want to be like that
and and i think that that is the culture
that it's it's the attitude of
it's you know i remember the dutch had
the same thing what is dutchness
and very quickly they would say i don't
know eating mashed potatoes
i don't think that's a big sell
i don't think many grown-ups want to eat
mashed potatoes
and also these are not the things that
make the west unique i mean there are
things
that have made the west as successful as
it's been you know freedom of expression
freedom of religion the scientific
method rationality you can go down the
list
these are the things that have made the
west as successful
as it is uh but you know it's for some
reason it's only people like
us that are allowed to talk about it if
a british-born british person was to say
these things they'd be called racist and
it doesn't make any sense i've i've
raised these questions so i'll say to
the germans
just for the fun of it i mean what is
really unique about being german they
they just shake their heads and say oh
eating sausages and drinking beer
and the french will say he'll talk about
frogs and wine
well to be honest with you i am the last
time the germans tried nationalism
it didn't end well did it
[Laughter]
that is true
we found out the hard way but now they
want
a tone for that
past by saying okay
immigrant men when they misbehave
and fail to integrate well tough luck
for their victims because our pastor is
so bad
that you know what um we're now
morally frozen that's exactly that's
literally what they say
they just talk about uh we can't do this
because
remember the holocaust
and he's in an irony so the jewish
minorities
in many of these european countries are
now being subjected
to a renewed anti-semitism where the far
right is coming out of the woodwork
because it's okay now to be anti-jewish
and
anti-semitic but it's now
hidden in this because the islamists are
coming in
declaring that the palestinians are
victims of
jewish hatred and so suddenly it's okay
to victimize
the jewish minorities but do you see
where that atonement mentality goes
to the jewish minority in germany
for whom we are atoning because we
massacred their ancestors
and we said never again are now leaving
germany they're leaving france they're
leaving
sweden to come here to the united states
or go to
israel because we're in the throes of
atonement
that's the logic i don't understand so
going back to the theme of
responsibility ion
what responsibility does the west have
to the middle east
when you can make a very very simple and
effective argument to say that a lot of
the problems that we now see in the
middle east were caused by the west
drawing these arbitrary lines on a map
creating countries
which are fundamentally unstable and can
really only be held together by
dictatorships or oppressive regimes
i think nudging through diplomacy
through economic relationships um
maybe even through development aid and
in i would say there is also a place for
defense
uh but so the the these big issues where
i think
you seek alliances you hold on to those
alliances
and you try and mitigate the problems
locally
in the middle east and elsewhere
not because you are turning for your
past
but because it is the rational thing to
do
because the unintended consequences of
mass
movements of you know broken countries
is going to destabilize your own country
that's a good point ayan and i'm aware
of the time we're very very grateful for
the time that you've already given us
uh it it's it will be a great pleasure
for us to have you in the studio of
course
whenever we're all allowed uh to be in
the same space so we'll see in 2027 but
until then i thoroughly recommend the
book pray
and of course you've got a new podcast
out as well haven't you
it's the aeon herciale podcast and we
just launched the ayan here's the ali
website
fantastic and with that we have one more
question for you which is of course
what is the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be
i think we're not talking enough about
what is happening
to the uyghur minority in china
to the women who are being
systematically raped
to the women who are being
systematically enforceably
sterilized um to the so-called
education which is really brainwashing
internments
and the genocide that china is carrying
out
on its weaker community of roughly about
10 million people
i am amazed at the silence
from muslim leaders in muslim
countries and even islamists you know
the political islamists
who would rant and rave
about the cartoons of the prophet
muhammad are now
really silent eerily silent
when their fellow muslims are being
subjected to genocide to internment
to sterilization to mass rape
that i think is a subject we're not
talking enough about
i earned her ciali thank you so much for
coming on the show we
absolutely loved this conversation and
we're certain that our audience will as
well
if you want to catch a trigonometry
episode or a live stream they always go
out at 7pm
uk time see you soon guys we hope you've
enjoyed this
incredible interview remember to
subscribe and hit the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below